merci Philippe Bas de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure
sénateur les républicains de la Manche
vous êtes questeur du Sénat membre de la
commission des lois et on va parler
évidemment de cette décision du Conseil
constitutionnel qui est attendu demain
en fin de journée est-ce que vous pensez
que la réforme sera validée
mais vous demandez à vos invités pas
seulement vous de d'être
de faire des pronostics moi je ne fais
pas de pronostic je respecte le rôle
spécifique du Conseil constitutionnel il
est le gardien du temple il fait
respecter la règle du jeu parlementaire
elle est inscrite dans la Constitution
et d'autre part il veille à ce que aucun
principe fondamental ne soit mis en
péril par une loi qui vient d'être votée
j'indique d'ailleurs que le Conseil
constitutionnel intervient en ultime
recours c'est d'abord au Parlement
lui-même de faire respecter les droits
fondamentaux et il le fait et le Sénat
le particulièrement parce que c'est un
peu sa marque de fabrique de préserver
les libertés alors le Conseil
constitutuel va se prononcer sur
plusieurs questions est-ce que la
procédure suivie respecte la
Constitution personne ne pourra dire que
cette procédure a été harmonieuse mais
est-ce qu'elle respecte la Constitution
c'est la seule question qui est posée au
Conseil constitutionnel et le Conseil
constitutionnel n'est pas une instance
d'appel du Parlement et il le dit
lui-même et donc sur le fond il veillera
tout simplement à ce que les droits
fondamentaux soient respectés il le dira
mais attendent de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel que le Conseil
constitution fassie ruption sur la scène
politique alors ça ça n'est pas une
bonne conception de son rôle la
politique de la nation elle est
déterminée par le gouvernement la loi
allait voter par le Parlement le Conseil
constituel il met simplement des gardes
de fou pour s'assurer qu'on n'a pas
franchi les limites
de la part de sur le fait que le Conseil
constitutionnel pourrait avoir être
tenté d'être un peu politisé qu'il y a
beaucoup de personnes qui ont été
nommées par des proches du chef de
l'État vous entendez c'est ces arguments
ah non je crois que quand on commence à
mettre en doute l'indépendance du
Conseil constitutionnel tous s'écroule
parce que en réalité les garanties
d'indépendance ne viennent pas seulement
des nominations nous signale que le
président du Sénat nomme trois membres
le président de l'Assemblée nationale en
homme 3 que le Président de la
République en homme 3 les personnalités
nommées au Conseil constitutuel sont
nommés pour neuf ans elles ne peuvent
pas être renouvelées et dès qu'elles
entrent dans l'institution elles sont
avant tout membres du Conseil
constitutionnel et elle laisse de côté
tous les engagements politiques qu'elles
ont pu avoir moi j'ai confiance à
l'égard du Conseil constitution et cette
petite musique est pernicieuse elle
délicieuse parce qu'elle revient à
préparer les esprits en cas de décision
qui dirait la conformité à la
Constitution de la loi à ce qu'on puisse
remettre en cause la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel au fond il y a des gens
en France quand on leur donne pas raison
et bien il trouve toujours un argument
pour dire qu'il y a eu quelque chose de
pas correct qui a été fait une turpitude
qui a été commise ça n'est pas comme ça
qu'on fait fonctionner un état de droit
sur le fond vous vous entendez la gauche
qui dénonce de multiples atteintes au
débat le recours à un budget
rectificatif vu comme un détournement de
procédure par la gauche il dénonce
d'utilisation du vote bloqué de
l'article 38 qui limite les temps de
débat vous entendez les arguments de la
gauche vous les comprenez ils sont
justifiés
tous ceux
qui ont participé au gouvernement de la
France ont été bien contents de trouver
dans la Constitution de la Cinquième
République des moyens évitants au
gouvernement d'être incapable d'agir
d'être immobile et c'est la raison
d'être de la Cinquième République que
d'avoir donné un certain nombre de
procédures juridiques pour que on puisse
aller au bout du vote de la loi plus
personne ne se souvient c'est normal
c'était avant 1958 des autres régimes de
la République et bien les gouvernements
étaient instables il tenaient quelques
mois trois mois six mois au plus un an
et exceptionnellement un an et on ne
pouvait pas voter de loi parce qu'il n'y
avait pas de majorité bien sûr la
Cinquième République on a voulu
stabiliser le régime et on a voulu des
gouvernements capables et non pas des
gouvernements incapables on peut s'en
plaindre quand on est dans l'opposition
je suis dans l'opposition
alors évidemment je m'en plains un peu
mais je me dis pour la France pas pour
l'opposition mais pour la France c'est
tout de même mieux de ne pas être dans
cette catégorie de pays qui se
caractérise par leur incouvernabilité
mais l'important quand on a des
procédures aussi contraignantes que
celle qui existe dans notre Constitution
c'est que ces procédures ne soient pas
abusivement utilisés et ça c'est le rôle
de conseil constitutionnel de le dire
les sages qui doivent aussi se prononcer
demain sur la validité du référendum
d'initiative partagée demandée par les
parlementaires de gauche ça sera bon et
de sortir de cette crise pour vous ça
sera surtout un moyen de la prolonger
parce que si vous voulez il y a un
moment il faut quand même passer à autre
chose
elle aurait pu être différente
c'est pas vrai de dire qu'il y a une
seule solution possible à un problème on
aurait pu soulever d'autres questions on
aurait surtout pu avoir un dialogue
social un peu plus fécond qui ne l'a été
parce qu'il n'a pas du tout été fécond
je me souviens à moi de la réforme qui
était la plus difficile pour les
retraites celle qui a étendu à la
fonction publique
la réforme des retraites en 2003 et il y
avait beaucoup d'oppositions mais il y a
eu un accord avec la CFDT la CFTC la CSC
et cet accord a fait bouger le
gouvernement de l'époque celui de
Monsieur Raffarin avec François Fillon
comme ministre en charge des retraites
et on a pris en compte les positions des
autres on a accepté d'augmenter un peu
la cotisation des employeurs on a
surtout inventé à cette époque le régime
qu'on appelle celui de la retraite
anticipée pour les carrières longues et
donc il y a eu un équilibre et bien vous
voyez dans cette réforme il n'y a pas eu
cet équilibre c'est ça le véritable
problème c'est le fait quand le
président de la République dit à la
télévision que les syndicats n'ont pas
proposé de compromis on croit rêver
parce que c'est quand même à l'exécutif
de faire un pas en avant envers les
syndicats
il y en a tout de même puisse dire ah
oui on a bien sûr un effort qui est
demandé aux Français mais il y a des
contreparties sérieux là il a dit qu'il
voulait les rencontrer après la décision
du Conseil constitutionnel c'est
opportun ou c'est trop tard pour vous on
a vu ce que ça a donné quand madame
bonne l'affaire alors souhaitons que si
le président de la République le fait ça
donne de meilleures résultats mais enfin
une réunion syndicale c'est pas fait
pour enfiler des perles vous voyez c'est
pas un théâtre d'ombre c'est pas un
dialogue de façade qu'est-ce que c'est
André Bergeron vous souvenez d'André
Bergeron il a été longtemps le
secrétaire général de Force Ouvrière il
disait il faut du grain à moudre
s'il y a du grain à moudre commençons
par le dire mettons-le sur la table et
vous allez voir appliquer les
organisations syndicales pour en
discuter et se le partager est-ce que la
sortie de crise elle passe par un accord
de gouvernement avec les républicains
je crois que le véritable obstacle à une
sortie de cette période d'entre-deux
d'un détermination c'est un système qui
nous a fait progressivement dérivé du
système initial de la 5e République dans
lequel le gouvernement est devenu un
gouvernement présidentiel au fond on dit
qu'on a présidentialisé le régime moi je
dirais on a gouvernementalisé le
président de la République et le Premier
ministre la première ministre n'est pas
un homme de paille mais est un peu
transparente dans tout ça et en réalité
à partir du moment où le président de la
République en tant gouvernait lui-même
l'accord est impossible mais s'il joue
son rôle d'arbitre s'il prend de la
hauteur
s'il laisse les forces politiques
discutées entre elles alors un espace
peut s'ouvrir mais cet espace est de
plus en plus réduit il n'est pas de plus
en plus large et s'il s'agissent
simplement de faire du débauchage
individuel que on traite son opposition
comme une force d'appoint comme des
supplétifs mais alors ça ne sert à rien
en quoi ça améliore le sort du pays ça
ne l'améliore pas du tout le président
continue à faire sa politique il ne
change rien et il prend quelques otages
de si de là pour donner une coloration
différente
à son action
de Premier ministre mais ce n'est pas
une évolution réelle c'est une évolution
fictive mais pour vous il faut redonner
de la place au rôle de premier ministre
mais est-ce que le premier ministre doit
être
issu de vos rangs il y a le nom de
Gérard Larcher qui circule mais vous
voyez s'apprête à sourire ce sont des
ballons décès nous avons un sénat libre
indépendant non alignés qui est un
véritable le rôle de stabilité dans la
République il doit le rester et il doit
beaucoup à son président nous tenons à
notre président et toutes ces
gesticulations non pas de sens ce qui
est important aujourd'hui c'est que le
Président de la République 10 ce qu'il
veut faire maintenant de ce qui lui
reste de quinquennat et est-ce que ce
quinquennat peut encore être utile après
la crise démocratique et sociale dans
laquelle nous sommes trouvés plongés on
va parler de l'actualité du Sénat qui
rejoint celle de la réforme des
retraites les dernières journées de
mobilisation contre la réforme et les
manifestations antibacines à
Sainte-Soline ont été marquées par des
violences Gérald Darmanin pour être
l'ultra gauche mais un débat un lieu sur
la stratégie du maintien de l'ordre et
hier à l'initiative de la majorité
sénatoriale le Sénat a voté un soutien
aux forces de l'ordre on voit ça avec
Audrey vital
[Musique]
bonjour
Audrey la majorité sénatoriale de la
droite et du centrale à adopter une
proposition de résolution exprimant la
gratitude et la reconnaissance du Sénat
au monde des forces de l'ordre oui avec
250 voix pour et 0 voix compte car la
gauche n'a pas souhaité prendre part à
ce vote ça explique donc le résultat il
s'agit d'une proposition déposée par
l'ensemble des LR et par la moitié du
groupe centriste soutenu par le
gouvernement je rappelle que c'est un
texte symbolique politique qui n'a pas
de visée normative l'objectif en fait
pour le Sénat c'est de prendre position
en l'occurrence cette proposition elle a
été déposée au lendemain des violents
affrontements de sainte Soline vous
l'avez dit elle a vu des images
d'affrontement la manifestation
antibacine qui a été infiltrée par des
militants radicaux ultra violents et
organisé on le voit sur ces images une
cinquantaine de fonctionnaires de police
a été blessé je vous propose d'écouter
Bruno Retailleau le président du groupe
les républicains au Sénat qui est
l'auteur de cette proposition
je pense que nous devons à la fois
prendre partie et finalement choisir son
camp le camp de l'ordre républicain ou
bien alors le camp d'une certaine forme
d'ambiguïté et même de complicité parce
que quand nous avons vu notamment Hassan
solide des élus mère ou parlementaires
fin de leur écharpe tricolore
assister à une manifestation qui était
interdite et dans tout le monde savait
qu'elle allait mal se terminer il faut y
voir je crois un signe de complicité qui
n'est pas admissible lorsqu'on est un
élu de la République
notre écharpe tricolore ne peut pas
servir à couvrir les exactions des
cagoules
alors
certains de ses collègues on sait par
exemple que le sénateur écologiste
Thomas do cieux a affirmé ou effort
avoir participé à cette manifestation
mais la réponse des écologistes on
l'aura pas car le président du groupe
Guillaume Gontard a renoncé à sa prise
de parole son groupe voulait en fait un
vote pour ne même pas étudier cette
proposition ça a été refusé les
écologistes qui ont de leur côté déposé
une autre proposition de résolution qui
demande notamment à la France de revoir
sa doctrine de maintien de l'ordre c'est
une question oui j'ai une question pour
Philippe
moi-même mon texte est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec Bruno Retailleau est-ce
que vous estimez que les élus qui ont
participé à cette manifestation couvrent
les exactions des Black Blocs
écoutez vous présenter avec des sharpes
tricolores pour mettre en cause
l'application d'une loi
ça je crois que ça n'est pas convenable
c'est simple vous êtes représentant de
la loi vous êtes représentant de la
nation vous votez la loi il y a
des tentatives
non pas d'exprimer des opinions non pas
de manifester légitimement à une
opposition mais
d'empêcher l'application des lois
d'entraver l'exercice des droits et
libertés tels qu'elles sont prévues par
la Constitution vous savez vous vous
référer à la Déclaration des Droits de
l'Homme article doux
proclame la nécessité de la force
publique pour garantir les droits
article 10 7 il programme comme
inviolable et sacré le droit de
propriété avec tous les attributs de ce
droit
l'article 4 qui dit que la liberté
s'arrête là où commence la mise en cause
de la liberté d'autrui
elle consiste à ne pas pouvoir faire ce
qui nuit à autrui et c'est la loi qui
doit l'empêcher la force publique elle
est là pour ça elle est là pour faire
respecter les droits fondamentaux il
faut pas avoir une conception sélective
des droits fondamentaux non retenir que
ce qui vous arrange il faut en retenir
que c'est un équilibre les auteurs de la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme ont
prévu cette équilibre et ceux qui mènent
des actions de force avec des armes on
appelle ça des armes par destination par
de faire boulon matériel d'artificiers
cela ils ne viennent pas manifester
ils viennent utiliser la violence la
violence n'est pas un produit d'une
dérive de la manifestation elle est
l'objet même
de
l'intervention d'un certain nombre
d'activistes qui sont venus spécialement
pour ça la force publique
elle ne se fait pas en gant blanc et en
escarpins une fois que vous avez décidé
de la mobiliser pour empêcher l'action
violente d'un certain nombre
d'activistes et malheureusement et c'est
désolant puis une fois qu'elle est
utilisée elle peut donner lieu
effectivement à des blessures mais ce
qui ont été agressés ce sont les
policiers et les gendarmes et il faut
penser que les policiers et les
gendarmes qui sont des pères des mers de
famille prennent des risques énormes
pour faire respecter la loi il y a un
moment où quand on les met à égalité
avec des commandos de
d'ultraviolos il faut s'indigner et il
faut rappeler que dans la République
dans l'étape droit c'est la force
publique n'est pas défendue alors c'est
la violence et l'anarchie qui règne dans
la rue et Audrey pour le reste de la
gauche faut pas avoir peur de
questionner le travail de la police oui
Jérôme Durand sénateur socialiste qui
est spécialiste de ces sujets à dénoncer
une résolution opportuniste un soutien
bien peu coûteux ce sont ces mots
d'après lui les forces de l'ordre n'ont
pas besoin d'un soutien symbolique mais
de moyens d'après lui aussi ça n'empêche
pas de critiquer les forces de l'ordre
je vous propose de l'écouter
posez ce texte dans une période où le
travail des forces de l'ordre est
questionné s'est déclaré à ceux qui
critiquent le travail de la police
circulez il n'y a rien à voir vous avez
choisi par ce texte d'exprimer une
gratitude inconditionnelle souvent un
peu par levier une gratitude d'ailleurs
assez stérile pour les forces de l'ordre
elle-même au groupe socialiste nous
préférons exprimer notre soutien de
principe parce que nous ne sommes pas
contre la police notre exigence de
principe parce que nous avons une haute
idée du rôle républicain des forces de
l'ordre c'est ce qui nous permet
d'exprimer notre inquiétude quand les
circonstances exigent c'est le cas en ce
moment s'agissant du maintien de l'ordre
alors parmi les prises de parole votre
collègue les républicains François
bonhomme a une nouvelle fois fustigé la
Ligue des droits de l'homme en décrivant
une association prétendument humanitaire
qui s'est livré à une mise en cause
indécente contre les policiers les
gendarmes vous êtes d'accord avec eux
il ne faut pas avoir je le répète une
vision sélective des droits de l'homme
sa forme à tout indissociable et quand
on proclame une liberté on prévoit aussi
que la loi en apporte les limites la
Ligue des droits de l'homme prend
actuellement des positions qui ne sont
pas conformes de mon point de vue à son
histoire parce que elle ne regarde
qu'une partie de la réalité et je crois
la première ministre semble être de mon
avis que elle
réduit les droits de l'homme
systématiquement à
des droits contre l'État or l'État est
là justement pour assurer la garantie
des droits et donc on est rentré là dans
une forme d'idéologie qui mérite à tout
le monde d'être questionné je le crois
merci Audrey à tout à l'heure oui on va
parler de l'hypothèse Gérard Larcher
Premier ministre on en parle ce sera
dans le club on va chez vous du côté de
Cherbourg retrouvez christmel marchand
bonjour chrismel merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous rédacteurs en chef adjointe de
la Presse de la Manche et chrismel on va
revenir avec vous sur les difficultés du
monde de la pêche dans la Manche et plus
largement en Normandie oui bonjour à
tous bonjour monsieur bain vous avez
récemment écrit Hervé Berville
secrétaire d'État chargé de la mer cette
occasion de réclamer le soutien des
pouvoirs publics en faveur de la filière
pêche alors les deux Léon sont
effectivement nombreuses entre
l'augmentation des charges une
diminution des zones de pêche ou la
limitation des droits de pêche notamment
raison du brexit dans la Manche une
récente mobilisation à Cherbourg devant
le comité régional des pêches à mis à
jour toutes ces pesanteurs ses freins
alors les questions est simple comment
sauver notre notre pêche artisanale
bonjour à La Presse de la Manche d'abord
et
oui en effet je suis intervenu avec ma
collègue Béatrice kossum et ça n'est pas
la première fois que nous le faisons
pour défendre la pêche artisanale au
fond qu'est-ce que nous constatons il y
a une politique européenne elle est
destinée aujourd'hui à préserver la
ressource halieutique en luttant contre
les les grands armements
les énormes paquebots de la pêche au
turière ses
usines qui fabriquent de la farine
empêchant immédiatement le poisson et en
fabriquant la farine immédiatement après
de la farine de poisson et qui ont pillé
les mers mais souvent on essaye de
régler ce problème au détriment de la
pêche artisanale on ne regarde pas dans
le détail des choses et notre pêche
artisanale aujourd'hui est en grand
péril il faut la protéger il faut la
défendre et il se trouve que dans la
revanche nous avons cumulé ces dernières
années les difficultés parce qu'il y a
eu le brexit parce qu'il y a eu des
négociations très longues et pénibles
qui heureusement obtenu un certain
nombre de résultats positifs avec les
îles anglo normandes mais aussi parce
que les règles qu'on a voulu imposer
pour restreindre le pillage des mers par
la pêche au turière on pourrait faire de
limiter aussi la possibilité pour notre
pêche artisanale sans payer les mers de
faire vivre nos artisans pêcheurs et
donc il faut aujourd'hui vraiment être
extrêmement vigilant et peser fort
auprès du gouvernement français pour que
lui-même pèse fort auprès de l'Union
européenne pour que on dise nous on
existe aussi ne nous oubliez pas
vous avez une autre question oui
[Musique]
de la pêche c'est l'éolien offshore nos
pêcheurs sont vend en debout contre les
nombreux projets en cours alors au large
du Cotentin vous êtes bien au bureau au
courant qu'il y a les deux plus grands
parcs de France qui vont voir le jour
alors selon vous comment est-ce qu'on
peut faire cohabiter les deux je me bats
avec les mères avec certaines
associations pour reculer le champ
d'éolienne en mer qui est prévue au
large de bafleur nous avons obtenu des
résultats puisque il était prévu à 13 km
des côtes il est reporté à 32 km des
côtes nous voulons atteindre 40 km nous
voulons le faire pour des raisons
environnementales mais nous voulons le
faire aussi pour la pêche pour
l'éloigner le plus possible des côtes et
puis nous devons aussi faire rentrer les
pêcheurs dans une forme de comité de
pilotage qui permettrait d'anticiper
un impact négatif ou positif dans
certains cas de ces champs d'éoliennes
en mer sur la pêche je crois que il y a
besoin d'une recherche appliquée pour
mesurer exactement cet impact et il faut
que les pêcheurs participent à cette
réflexion pour qu'on prenne et toute
mesure utile pour que la compatibilité
entre le développement de ces énergies
marines renouvelables pour lesquelles à
Cherbourg on a beaucoup investi avec la
transformation du port pour accueillir
l'activité de production des pales
d'éoliennes en mer et bien il faut que
la compatibilité du développement de ces
énergies marines renouvelables avec la
pêche soit garantie et pour ça il faut
que la transparence soit totale
est-ce que on le voit un cric Ismaël l'a
dit les temps sont difficiles pour les
pêcheurs est-ce que vous estimez que le
gouvernement soutient assez le monde de
la pêche mais on ne soutient jamais
assez le monde de la pêche mais nous ne
voulons pas non plus un criminé
spécialement le gouvernement dans une
politique qui est européenne ce que nous
lui demandons c'est de se battre plus
activement encore pour faire en sorte
que la pêche artisanale qui est notre
problème à nous c'est pas la pêche au
turière avec ses grands équipements qui
dévastent les mers donc nous avons une
flottie de pêche qui a beaucoup de
mérite nous avons pour la coquille
Saint-Jacques des marins-pêcheurs qui
ont ensemencé
nos côtes pour développer la ressource
et qui sont très soucieux de
l'environnement et bien nous devons
imposer à l'Europe de bien prendre en
compte leurs intérêts car il joue pour
la ressource aliotique qui ne joue pas
le contraire
merci merci chrismaël marchand c'est la
tempête Noah qui est à la Une de votre
journal aujourd'hui la tempête Noah
secoue le content c'est elle a une de la
Presse de la Manche merci beaucoup
christmel marchand d'avoir été avec nous
ce matin et merci Philippe Bas merci
c'est notre invité à très vite
évidemment on est toujours ravi de vous
recevoir dans 20 minutes dans le club
des territoires débat entre Pascal
Perrineau et l'orange aufrain notamment
sur les sujets dont on a parlé réforme
d'un traite et comment Emmanuel Macron
peut en sortir ce sera à suivre d'abord
on a qu'à une prochaine invité Alexis
Corbière nous rejoindre